these are the English and American
versions of the same book of my book on
numbers
the English version Alex's adventures in
numberland which was the first title I
came up with then when we took it to the
American publishers they said who's Alex
not going to work in America so he came
up with another one which is kind of
funny he is looking at Euclid which when
I then suggested the British publishers
they said well who's Euclid so it
actually works really well for both
different territories because in America
it seems that everyone has heard of
Euclid and I'm not sure I'm never sure
if this is because Americans have better
geometry lessons or if it's because
Euclid appears a lot more in street
names than city names in the u.s.
actually my theory is that the reason
why the Americans named cities and
streets after Euclid is because the
founding fathers were masons and the
Masons were big into geometry
I studied maths and philosophy at
university but then I became a
journalist and then I ended up as a
foreign correspondent in Brazil and so
when excited right about math I decided
to write about math in the way that a
foreign correspondent would write so I
travel all around the world interviewing
different people to do with numbers at
maths and it seemed to me that in a
sense I was doing just what I was doing
as a foreign correspondent but I wasn't
going to any one country I was going to
a kind of fictitious country numberland
so in the same way that when I was in
Brazil I would fly to the Amazon and do
a report and then explain it to people
who'd never been there in numberland I
kind of fly to the land of algebra or
the land of geometry explain it come
back and give a report to explain to
people who don't really understand the
land of algebra or geometry and explain
how it is so I was also lucky that I've
had about 20 translations and I've got
some of them here which has been done so
we start here with Italian email every
lousier mondo day normally there are
lots of books around and there are lots
of books on numbers but I guess I felt
there was a gap in the market for a book
about numbers that was accessible to the
lay reader in a way that other books
haven't been you know there have been
books written aimed at the lay reader
and some of them should be very
successful but nothing really that's
been written by a news reporter Alex or
bedi schifflet which is the French one a
leg sin el pase de los nomads ass which
is a Spanish one I hoped it would work I
didn't know whether it would I thought
maybe one of the reasons what has been
done before is that it's impossible to
do but actually using reportage and
journalism to write about maths I think
works and I think I have brought a new
audience even if everything is quite
small a new audience - buying books
about maths and definitely if you read
the Khan
so that comeback the feedback about the
book you know you do get lots of people
saying oh my god I've never been
interested in math before but I read
this and you know it's quite interesting
ketover Mathematica with a little joke
on Pi there which is finish
I like snow based on orders from Brazil
always when I'm writing I'm thinking you
know could the man on the street
read this you know maybe slightly
educated man with streak because there
are lots of people who you just put a
number in there they don't understand it
at all but could someone who you know if
you can read freakanomics understand if
you can read the financial pages of a
newspaper if you can if you've got GCSE
maths you should be able to get quite a
lot out of qui right what's the aim get
to lilandra's silt or Catalan maybe
which is Dutch and that's the American
is looking at Euclid pace is very
difficult because you need to go slow
enough to take everyone with you but not
so slow that people who understand it
get a little bit bored so how do you do
that you need to kind of sugar the pill
by including lots of interesting kind of
color and observation because too much
of that cuz it looks like you you just
just filler
essentially what you need is you need a
really strong narrative you need people
to want to know what's going to happen
and actually my favorite is the German
one which is here Alex
in Wonderland it's Alan because it's got
this fantastic picture of me kind of
surfing in abacus in my slippers but I
don't know which picture they used but
I've got you there and then we zoom in
on on the oh you know yeah it looks a
bit like you it is said that the minute
you put an equation in a piece of text
you lose half the readers I don't think
that's true if you put it in you know if
you build up the equation then you
explain it well enough but still you
can't have that many equations there's
always got to be more words than there
are none
or equations per page and that can be
quite difficult because math naturally
has lots of numbers and equations in it
is your book about numbers or is your
book about math no my book is about
maths and I started to write my book
about math without having a title for it
and it was only halfway through that the
title came up but even though I was over
at maths
most people think what matters numbers
are the same thing so you know the first
hundred pages of my book is really about
numbers the birth of numbers where'd
they come from people who tribes that
don't have numbers animals that
understand numbers based systems why we
can up to ten and not twelve say or
eight so I think that numbers is
essentially where math starts and in any
book about maths you need to kind of
cover that area but actually maths is
about you know structure and pattern and
logic and proofs and elegance and all
those other things and sometimes think
think with numbers is that numbers in
themselves are actually quite dry that
you need to use numbers to explain other
things when you look back and read the
book now yeah are there things you wish
you'd done differently other things you
look at and go I could have done that
better or do you look at it and think
happy with that um I think you are most
writers what do they think when they
read their books they just cringe with
embarrassment
so you it's not so far in the past that
I don't look at it and think oh I should
have done that bit better that's not
quite good enough but actually in terms
of sales and reviews and claim I can't
complain so I guess I must be happy with
it
you